Donald Trump is demanding a redo of the
2022 election in Arizona
in what we are calling an electron rant
an electron rant this is really up there
as an iconic presidential moment of all
time and you'll see what I mean in a
moment Donald Trump posting to his
platform truth social truth essential
quote so in Maricopa County they are at
it again voting machines in large
numbers didn't work but only in
Republican districts remember this isn't
true there were like a couple tabulators
that had an issue everything was fine
people were forced to wait for hours
then got exhausted or had other things
to do and left the voting Lines by the
thousands even Kerry Lake was taken to a
liberal Democrat District in order to
vote others weren't so lucky now
remember
nobody was told to leave and go to other
polling places it was a republican who
was actually doing that okay this is a
scam and voter fraud no different than
stuffing the ballot boxes they stole the
capital E electron from Blake Masters do
election over again ladies and gentlemen
we have nothing to fear but fear itself
ask not what your country can do for you
but what you can do for your country
we do things not because they are easy
but because they are hard
they stole the electron due election
over again really an iconic moment
inspiring and just Electric in
presidential statements of History
forget the typo okay for a second as
funny as it is it is shocking that a
former president still doesn't know how
the vote counting process works it
times do we have to do this until Trump
will understand or any of them quite
frankly
why it is that votes are counted the way
they're accounted and I think it's
important to remind people again in many
of these states the votes are counted
the way they are accounted because of
Republican legislatures that have put in
place the rules for how the vote count
Works add to that by the way that at
this point the most scrutinized state in
terms of voting security is probably
Arizona maybe Pennsylvania to some
degree because of what happened in 2020
but there is no state that is more
scrutinized than Arizona
within Arizona I don't think there's any
County more scrutinized than Maricopa
County at this point in time because of
what happened in 2020 thanks to Trump in
other words because of all the claims
Trump made in 2020 about Arizona Arizona
and Maricopa County are now insanely
scrutinized even though there's no
particular need to do it and now he's
saying oh yeah there was fraud again it
was fraught just as fraudulent again
and uh it is unbelievable that people
continue to fall for this but sadly this
is now standard operating procedure we
we didn't know
back in uh 2020. whether
it was rigged it was stolen would become
a broader calling card or a more
frequent refrain for Republicans but it
is very clear that that is now the case
if they lose it was rigged the world is
laughing and that's where we are at this
point in time
plastic is everywhere we look and not
enough is being done about it 100
billion plastic bags are used and thrown
away every year but you can help make a
change our sponsor hold on makes trash
and kitchen bags that are heavy duty
plant-based non-toxic and 100 percent
home compostable which means they break
down in weeks rather than decades they
don't fill up our landfills they don't
pollute our oceans they're zip seal
kitchen bags come in sandwich or gallon
bag sizes to fit your needs and the best
part about hold on bags is they work I
use them at home they're just as good as
all of the name brand bags you fill them
up they stretch and they don't break
everybody uses trash bags and freezer
bags if you care about the planet you
can do something by using hold on bags
instead and it's a really easy way to do
your part go shop plant-based bags to
replace single-use Plastics all over
your home you'll save 20 20 percent when
you go to holdon bags.com Pacman and use
the code Pacman the link is down below